benvenuti alla seconda puntata di
temptation islands zip
[Musica]
qui ice morus relais i fidanzati e
fidanzate stanno spiegando loro amore ma
ascoltando loco iniziamo col falò delle
ragazze fidanzate benvenute al falò
valeria pensi che abbia dei filmati per
te io spero di sì ma penso di no perché
ho visto anche nei video delle altre
patrick non prende mai una posizione
cioè non si fa mai avanti come sembra di
essere entrata qui da sola
spero ci sia un filmato per me se non ci
fosse sarebbe una delusione
valeria non ci sono video per te è lo
sapevo io nella mia vita mi sento sola
perché non mi confronto si ma valeria
dopo il palo rientra nel villaggio delle
fidanzate quella che vediamo è una
valeria che smette i panni stellari per
indossare i panni di una donna comune e
ritis cioè agli altri fidanzati parlano
delle loro fidanzate
lui no cioè io mi sono messa in
discussione anche io ho bisogno di
capire di cosa ho bisogno
no guarda mi viene da piangere ma
lamenta però perché tu piange non mi
ricorda busta il tremendo tremendo e
arrivato il momento dei falò dei
fidanzati per patrick saranno momenti
difficili patrick pensi che abbia un
video per te ma penso di sì hai ragione
padre o un video per te
io quando sto con te sono felice anche
io sono felice
ami me piace tantissimo parlare con te
sto prendendo delle decisioni sai che
decisioni e non posso dirtelo però lo
devi dire a me perché io posso aiutarti
io ho bisogno di te io invece ho bisogno
delle foto lenta e le vai a prendere
valeria sta facendo un percorso da sola
senza avere rispetto della persona
dall'altra parte hai preso delle
decisioni
va bene comuni camere quali sono queste
prenditi del tempo per fare chiarezza
patrick per nicoletta è tempo di pineto
quello che vedrà del fidanzato stefano
non le piaceva per niente anzi la farà
cadere nello sconforto totale
stefano ma che fai ma che stai facendo
cosa guardi stefano perché dici ste cose
io chiedo al confronto ho bisogno di
parlare col stefano nicoletta mi
dispiace ma stefano non ha accettato il
confronto e l'aspettavo seymour lui ha
paura ma paura di cosa allora li paga e
perché non mi ama
nicoletta secondo me stefano ti sta
dando dei segnali su questi segnali
dialetti il segnale così come rimandi mi
dispiace tu però sei scappando da questa
situazione
tu ci tieni a questo rapporto unico sì
ma non ci riesco simo io sono forte ma
non ci riesco pensaci nicoletta continua
questo percorso fallo per te tutto è
pronto per il falò di nilufar nilufar mi
dispiace ma un video per te ma cenavo
fa riflessioni che fanno meno nome pop
io amo in due città diverse
ci vediamo una due volte a settimana
perché io vado a roma altrimenti non ci
si vede
ci sono momenti in cui ho neanche mi
sento fidanzata simona neanche tre mesi
due volte a cena fuori da soli io
neanche a quella non puoi
categoricamente infilarsi nel letto del
mio fidanzato
il mio fidanzato non balla naso al naso
con una sì sì è vero sono d'accordo è
vero se non puoi non puoi guardare le
con quella faccia perché con quella
faccia quelli meno lei perché lei non è
nessuno tra canosa a naso con una ma
tutto a posto
ma che cosa nel cervello pangrattato e
io io amo da impazzire da impazzire
per me nessuno è paragonabile a lui per
me nessuno al valore che a lui per me
lui sta qua e gli altri sono soglia tre
camion a vomitare e ora passiamo al falò
di giordano giordano tu sei venuto qui
per dipanare dei dubbi che hai sul tuo
rapporto con il far come stai vivendo
questa esperienza come ti senti che ho
da video che ho visto l'altra volta
c'ero rimasto parecchio male perché
comunque le poche volte che parlava deve
né sminuiva sempre e non va bene
situazione nicolò sta iniziando a far
innervosire parecchio perché noi siamo
entrati qui dentro e tu mi hai detto no
nicolò ma chi ci parla poi ogni video
che vedo lei sta parla con nicolò e non
va bene
giordano o un video per te
ma che l'ho mai dimostrato che ti ama
cioè lui non ha cura dei tuoi interessi
non fa nulla di quello che fai tu per
lui è il classico tipo cioè che si fa a
lasciare capito
cioè tu devi mettere sempre al primo
posto la tua felicità nilu sempre vedo
che sono passati tre mesi e un'altra
volta vedevo vede nicolò che parla con
il fard e me dei miei io nilo farlo dopo
una dimostrazione che nessun altro
ragazzo che avrebbe mai dato
e lei continua a sminuirne ma che cosa
ci sta fa con me va bene giordano puoi
andare stefano ti chiedo di rimanere con
me qui al falò va bene allora stefano
nicoletta questa mattina ha richiesto un
altro fallo di confronto ecco visto che
se qui volevo chiedertelo accetti questo
falò di confronto anticipato o no il
fatto che lei sia rimasta per me è stata
una grande dimostrazione
se tu mi dici che lei richiesto il falò
di confronto io sarò ben felice insomma
di farlo
[Musica]
stefano io quel giorno ho lasciato la
tua mano perché ero sicura del nostro
amore
eravamo sul veliero e se mi hai detto ti
amo
nicoletta noi siamo venuti qui per fare
un percorso
io te lo dissi prima di entrare che lo
volevo fare fino alla fine questo
percorso
stefano io ho pianto per te tutti i
giorni perché mi mancava come l'aria è
invece festa visto lo stare con quelle
donne
hai detto perché ti sei da bar aliena ma
ti rendi conto
io ho visto delle cose che mi hanno
fatto rimanere molto male nicoletta
questo percorso doveva servirgli non ci
è servito a niente e hai fatto schifo
stefano io non sono venuto qua per
soffrire ma lo vede in scia delle
problematiche che il profumo che ti
tappa la vena ma scherziamo stefano
ma cosa uno adesso non si può manco
divertire io lo vede a differenza tua
mi preme quello che penso io quello che
provo io tu invece hai mille insicurezze
nicoletta io non so più chi sa e stefano
non ti riconosco nicoletta bisogna che
tu cresca tutti i giorni a pranzo e cena
fuori
ma io quante volte ti ho detto che
volevo cucinare per te e tu che mi
volevi sempre portare fuori ma cucinare
cosa i sofficini degli anni eletta dai
sei cattivo stefano perché se non mi
vuoi far trovare io volevo provare a
cucinare the nicoletta soffre
l'inferiorità the ai problemi io ero
bionda stefano io mi sono fatta mora
solo per far felice te a me non mi piace
questo colore perché mi appassisce mi
rende meno appariscente ma se ti hanno
detto tutti che stai centomila volte
meglio dai io ho paura di stefano ma di
cosa e paura di cosa nuvoletta ho paura
di perderti sete non buona persona così
lasciami come far star male devo fare la
domanda finale
nicoletta e vuoi uscire con stefano o da
sola
con stefano e tu stefano si voglio
uscire con nicoletta perché l'amo perché
tutta la mia vita sono stato senza di
lei in questi giorni e devo dire che
l'ho pensata tantissimo sei tutta la mia
vita ma non me le dici mai queste cose
stefano io ho bisogno di sentirmi dire
che le dirò bambolina via fanno il
sorriso dai dammi un bacetto buona
fortuna ragazzi vi auguro di prendere il
meglio di questa avventura e di farne
tesoro
concludiamo questa puntata con la nostra
valeria una donna dalle mille
sfaccettature una donna che alterna la
sua passione per il cibo che spesso
rappresenta una fuga dalla realtà al suo
essere di fan le cotolette quella che
volevo io ho buono questo luogo perché
noi sappiamo dare solo baci stellare
buonissima la caramella no ragazze ci
dobbiamo preparare mezz'ora ma io non ce
la faccio non disposto la parola una
cosa pazzesca
non mi devo ancora fare i capelli trucco
cioè non ce la farò mai mezz'ora
ed eccoci arrivati alla fine della
puntata come sempre vi ricordo se non
l'avete ancora fatto di iscrivervi al
mio canale e di lasciarvi un bel live
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social per
rimanere sempre aggiornati e per vedere
altre imitazioni tutto questo è un
viaggio nei sentimenti
tutto questo che i tempi e shawn island
vip alla prossima puntata
[Musica]